Speaker 1: Let's go next to Joe
from New Hampshire. Joe from New
Hampshire. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Awesome. I have kind of a
two parter for you. Sure. You know, I'm living
on a college campus right now, and I would say it
goes without saying that most people around here
are more political than the average population.
Sure. But even then, I mean, probably the majority
of people, I mean, are would consider themselves
apolitical. They don't like to touch politics.
Speaker 1: Interesting.
Speaker 3: And I'm noticing a lot of people I
mean, just in general seem to think that like
being apolitical is some kind of virtue. Hmm.
Speaker 1: Yeah, It's similar to enlightened
centrism. There are people who believe that
because they're in the middle and they're like,
Well, listen, you know, one side wants to kill
transpeople and the other wants them to be able
to use whatever bathroom they want. I'm in the
middle. It's like you're in the middle of one
position. That's crazy, dude. You know? So I think
the enlightened centrism is similar in a way,
but I also don't want to. Now, let me say
one thing here, Joe, before you move on.
Speaker 3: Right.
Speaker 1: I don't think that political apathy
is a good thing because political apathy, carried
to its full conclusion, allows small groups of
extremists to basically decide how our entire
political system works. So I think knowing what's
going on and voting very, very important, at the
risk of turning people off from my own program,
I do think there are some people who are too
sucked in to political issues and events and
news that will never affect them and that they
will never affect. And there are people who
have written about this. It's not nihilism,
but it's sort of understanding, you know,
okay, what am I going to do about what's
going on in Ukraine or the South China Sea
or Bubba blah, blah, blah. And I've seen for
some people it becomes unhealthy where they're
so sucked into news and politics, they're just
upset. They're not doing and on a lot of things,
they can't do anything about it other than I might
occasionally donate to a cause or vote or whatever
the case may be. And so I do think it's important
and I do this myself. I think shows like mine,
if you imagine like a pyramid instead of a food
pyramid, it's like an information pyramid. I
should be at the top of the pyramid, sort of
like the junk food. You're using this to fill
in your understanding of news and events built
on an understanding of history and other areas
built on a foundation of critical thinking
and epistemology. And there are some people
who are just constantly consuming opinion. And
I don't think that that's a good thing to do.
Speaker 3: Yeah, absolutely. I definitely agree.
I think my main concern is that there's a lot of
people who, for instance, in my state in New
Hampshire, we elected to Democratic senators,
but we reelected the the anti-abortion
Republican Republican governor. Yes. And
I was talking with some people after after I
personally voted and they were talking about
who they voted for. And they're like, yeah,
you know, I'm not too political. So. But,
you know, I still like abortion. So I voted
for the two Democratic senators and the and
Chris Sununu because they thought Chris Sununu
was pro-abortion. Right. And they just, like,
were not critical of who they were voting for.
Speaker 1: Yes. No, that's a real problem. And
I also know people who are like, yeah, I'm not
really political, but I just am kind of more
of a Republican. So I don't get very involved or
pay attention, but I just vote for Republicans.
But I'm not really very political. And then
I talk to the person and all of their views
actually really align more with the Democratic
Party. So sometimes that apathy is actually more
destructive than people who are involved.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's. That's
kind of what I was thinking, too. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, Joe, I appreciate your breaking
bringing up the issue. It's an important one.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Joe
from New Hampshire. Great to hear from.